when they ask you to do SNL host it
would you set what obviously said yes
but what was you what were you feeling
well it was a mixture of like because
again this is kind of the beginning and
I was like
I was I think couldn't believe it and
then it was full Panic oh yeah it was
holy [__] like I can't believe this and
I was like
I don't know if I can do it I've never
done anything like live TV I never
you know
I was oh I was so I was that was the
most
scared I've ever been but it was after a
few weeks after 9 11.
and I remember my friend my best friend
saying like because I was like I think
we're doing press for like one of the
second American Pie movie
and I have so like nervous about SNL
he's like listen there has never been a
more important time to try to make
people laugh
so I just leaned into that but that
whole week I don't think I ate any I
didn't eat anything I was so stressed
but then when
we did it that you know you do I think
two performances and ones taped a little
bit earlier
and then you just like you say there's
only two ways to go either commit or
you're in this awful like limbo world
where if you're making the entire
country uncomfortable because they can
see your fear but um yeah yeah it was an
incredible experience but yeah I
couldn't believe it
you know and isn't maybe I'm wrong but
isn't like Will Ferrell the greatest
Will Ferrell moments isn't your moment
in there on his the best one of them
yeah because oh my God it's like
when we did the rehearsal board I think
like the dress rehearsal
yeah it's in the office scene right and
he's like wearing a patriotic like flag
or whatever yeah like but they're like
Speedos I think yeah and um
when we did the dress rehearsal he he
propped his leg up and you can see his
balls leg the inside of his leg was like
all like a raw steak it was [__]
crazy and because he was training for a
marathon I think and he got his shape
and so when we did the thing on on live
TV his balls were out I mean he was
balls were there
is she had a weird raw steak leg it was
really hard to not and you don't see
that on film you don't see any of that
no no but I think that's why I mean also
he's hilarious so but if you watch that
scene I think Horatio is laughing 80
pullers in it like
because I think part of it is like his
little ball was like I'm sorry am I
saying will has a little ball but like
but his balls were hanging out just
saying hello you know I I remember when
I was a kid this is a complete
non-sequitur I was on the couch with my
dad and he just was swimming and he had
these little blue trunks on and he's
just sitting there watching the Mets
sitting on a towel and I looked over and
I saw one of his shiny balls and I just
remember going Dad one of your balls is
hanging out your pants and instead of
going Jesus Christ
he [__] turned it on me he got so mad
he blew up he goes
you know go to your go to your [__]
room get out of here you animal get out
they are not your balls it was like it
was funny it's respective I was like
what why are you yelling at me they were
your balls in your pants show you get
out of here